habt keine angst
das waren die ersten worte
der ersten öffentlichen rede des ersten
polnischen papstes nach seiner wahl im
oktober
johannes der 2
und worte die die welt verändert
johannes paul hatte die botschaft hier
in warschau gebracht und als er zuerst
als papst wieder zurück kam im juli
1979 damals sprach er die worte es war
eine wirtschaft von stärke von vertrauen
von stärke und einem starken volk
das gesicht einer kalten und zu teilen
regierung
die vor 30 jahren
dazu führt dass sich europa vor 30
jahren komplett verändert hat und
brachte diese botschaft
die sowjetunion
regierte damals mit eiserner hand hinter
dem eisernen vorhang ein jahr später
begann eine solidaritätsbewegung
empfohlen von hier ging sie auch
nicht dankbarer sein und alle amerikaner
mit mir
[Applaus]
vertrauen sieht man am besten im dunkeln
und
dunkle oder hoffnung sieht man am besten
im dunklen das waren dunkle momente zehn
jahre später zerfiel die sowjetunion und
polen polen und aus europa waren
frei und das war die gruppe der freiheit
einer der langen schweren zeit
und dann entstand etwas neues
große freiheit für demokratie der kampf
zwischen demokratie und auto
oratorischen freiheit und depression
zwischen rechtsstaatlichkeit
und brutaler macht in diesem
muss uns eines klar sein diese wird
nicht in tagen oder styrol sacken
geworden wir müssen uns stellen für
einen langen kampf
herr präsident
herr premierminister herr bürgermeister
lieber abgeordnete sehr verehrte gäste
polnische volk und ich denke es sind
auch einige menschen aus der ukraine
hier
wir haben uns hier versammelt
schloss in einer stadt die einen
heiligen platz hat nicht nur in europa
sondern in der
menschheit in der über generationen lang
hat warschau eine rolle der wird im
kampf um freiheit und die freiheit hat
letztendlich
[Applaus]
nach amerika und sie wurde eine starke
verfechterin der demokratie war ein
freund
amerikanische außenministerin vor drei
tagen
ist sie von uns gegangen sie hat ihr
ganzes leben für die demokratische
prinzipien gekämpft
dass die ukraine ihr
wissen und ihre nation zu verteidigen zu
erhalten für ssl demokratische
prinzipien die alle freien menschen
vereine
staatlichkeit faire und freie wahlen
meinungsfreiheit versammlungsfreiheit
sind
grundlegend für eine freie
wurden immer bekämpft sie muss ich hier
immer parterre worten werden alle
generationen
ist die welt aufgebaut
wie wir wissen
einige wenige haben ambitionen und den
abriss die mehrheit zu unterdrücken eine
botschaft an das libysche volk folgende
das habe ich auch heute schon dem
russischen verteidigungsminister und
außenminister gesagt die sind glaube ich
jetzt auch hier wir sind an eurer seite
[Applaus]
das ist eine schlafeinlage
kam
1956 polen
slowakei 0
268 9
demokratischen aufstände und die einzige
wieder widerstand setzte sich
endlich die berliner mauer und alle
bauern die die menschen
voneinander fern hielt vielen der kampf
um demokratie
ist noch nicht zu ende oder war nicht zu
ende am ende des kalten krieges in den
letzten 30 jahren haben die kräfte der
autokratie neue kraft gesammelt überall
auf der welt
gefährden die rechtsstaatlichkeit und
gefährden die wahrheit
um ihre freiheit
und russland
einmarschiert eben eine in ein freies
land es hat er hat ja shooting hat
gesagt die ukraine
entnazifizierung es ist eine lüge ist
ziemlich und er weiß das und es ist
obszön
präsident oder demokratisch gewählt er
ist jude sein vater oder großvater
starben im rathaus
glauben sich immer recht mainland und
linke hat den geist ausgesprochen
gesagt lasst uns dafür terrain darüber
das rennen gemacht wird und lasst uns
diese hoffnung heute wieder zum ausdruck
bringen und
die demokratie stärken und zu konkreten
aktionen kommen um die autokratien zu
bekämpfen das ist der test dieses
augenblicks
[Musik]
ist ein wunderbares projekt und es
stabilisiert sie stimmt stabil
stabilisiert russland nicht die nato ist
ein verteidigungs packt sie hat ja nie
vor ausgang zu bedrohen
im vorfeld der gegenwärtigen krise hat
die nato und die usa
monate lang daran gearbeitet
russland von dem schlechten weg
abzubringen
wir haben diplomatische versuche
unternommen doch und noch und wir waren
dabei wir wollten vertrauen aufbauen der
alle seiten aber sind in
russland haben all unsere vorschläge zu
nichte gemacht und alle verhandlungen
torpediert denn seine
gewalt
die grenzen überschreiten und das haben
wir gesagt und sie werden attackieren
und er sagt mir mehrfach er hätte kein
interesse daran krieg zu führen er hat
mehrfach erklärt er würde nicht in die
ukraine ein maschinen marschieren und er
hat gesagt er hätte gruppe nur zu
manöver zwecken zusammengezogen es gab
überhaupt keine provokation und russland
hat den krieg gewählt
haben gewalt angewandt und der situation
des information um
absolvierte er macht zu erlangen
aber es gibt eine internationale
eine internationale ordnung seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg
das gefährdet er nun und er gefährdet
die viele jahrzehnte friedlichen
zusammenlebens wir dürfen nicht wieder
da hin zurück
nicht einmal
das wagnis eingehen der solisten ist so
einig und so heftig mächtig
russland sanktionen auferlegt
und russland bestrafen um es zu bewegen
seinen kurs zu ändern wir haben die
wirtschaft russlands nahm lahm gelegt
und stand ist von swift abgeschnitten
haben das herz der russischen wirtschaft
getroffen dem wir die importe russischer
energieträger in die usa oder kunden
haben wir haben die oligarchen mit
sanktionen belegt und andere die
darreichung von mir den wir haben mehr
als 400
russische regierungsvertreter mit
sanktionen belegt offizielle und
oligarchen die riesige vermögen
angehäuft haben aufgrund der korruption
des kremls und nun müssen sie den preis
zahlen der privatsektor hat ebenfalls
reagiert mehr als 40 private
multinationale unternehmen haben
russland komplett verlassen
mcdonald's zb
im ergebnis dieser beispiellosen
sanktionen ist der regel sehr stark
gesunken
[Applaus]
also ein dollar kostet der 200 rubel und
die wirtschaft wird halbiert in den
letzten jahren die waren die elftgrößte
wirtschaft in der welt
vor dem einmarsch und jetzt werden sie
auch bald nicht mehr unter den führenden
20 der welt zu finden sein
wie
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen
sehr stark sie werden die wirtschaft
schädigen und die militärmaschine
und es ist
die mir putin der der anwalt ist
sich neben weiteren wirtschaftlichen
sanktionen
werden die westlichen
ukrainische volk will manni tere hilfe
zukommen lassen wir haben mehr als 650
millionen dollars geschickt bevor die
grenze überschritten wurde und seit der
invasion und
wir haben
und wir haben haben sichergestellt dass
die ukraine habe sich verteidigen kann
und unsere verbündeten kannten uns zur
seite aber die
amerikanischen militärs sind nicht in
europa um mit russischen militärs zu
reparieren oder zu kämpfen sondern sie
sind hier um europa zu verteidigen
gestern habe ich mich mit amerikanischen
truppen getroffen
und
ich einmal der gedanke zugelassen werden
sollte einen schritt
territorium zu machen wir haben eine
heilige verpflichtung unter artikel 5
jedem zentimeter
nato territorium zu verteidigen
und heute habe ich ein stadium wo
tausende von flüchtlingen untergebracht
waren und sie haben die schlimmsten
fragen gestellt die menschen stellen
können mein gott was passiert mit mir
was passiert mit meiner familie ich sah
tränen in den augen von müttern als ich
sie umarmte ich sah kleine kinder und
ich wusste nicht ob sie echt oder die
wussten nicht ob sie lächeln sollten
oder weinen ein kleines mädchen sagt der
herr präsident sie sprach ein bisschen
englisch wird mein vater und mein bruder
werden sie okay sein werde ich sie
wiedersehe und es gibt so viele männer
und väter und brüder und schwestern die
zurückgeblieben sind um ihr land zu
kämpfen man muss aber die sprache nicht
verstehen um die emotionen zu verstehen
um zu verstehen was die augen sagen
und ich sah dass diese kinder voller
verzweifelte hoffnung sind dass all das
nur zeitweilig sein möge und sie
fürchteten aber dennoch dass sie
womöglich für immer von zu hause fort
bleiben mussten und es ist furchtbar
dass das immer und immer wieder passiert
und
ich war überwältigt von der
großzügigkeit der menschen in warschau
und aller polnischen menschen die eine
hand gereicht haben und ihre herzen
geöffnet haben
sie haben nicht nur ihre herzen geöffnet
sondern auch ihre wohnungen ihre häuser
um einfach nur zu helfen und ich möchte
meinem freund josé anders und seinem
team danken
der dabei hilft diese menschen zu
verpflegen und
das darf natürlich nicht auf den
schultern polen allein
verbleiben alle
menschen der welt müssen helfen und die
menschen der ukraine können sich auf die
amerikaner verlassen wir werden ihnen
helfen wir werden 100000
ukrainische flüchtlinge aufnehmen
wer dem 300 millionen dollar humanitärer
hilfe leisten und
dutzende von 1000 tonnen von
nahrungsmitteln in brüssel hatte ich
erklärt dass die usa eine milliarde
dollar zur verfügung stellen wird ein
humanitärer hilfe und
ein bisschen
leiden der ukrainischen bevölkerung zu
lindern obwohl das natürlich nur ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein ist und
mario pohl zum beispiel wo die
russischen militärs die stadt
unter einer blockade halten
und wir werden den menschen helfen die
die stadt verlassen konnten und die die
ukraine verlassen konnten wir sehen
jetzt die brutalität von
präsident putin aber es kann keinen
zweifel daran geben dass dieser krieg
jetzt schon eine strategische niederlage
für russland darstellt
[Applaus]
ich habe selbst kinder verloren ich weiß
dafür kann es keine
das kann niemand heilen diesen schmerz
aber
routine merkt und seine armee dass die
ukraine ein starker gegner ist und
sollte
also auseinander dividieren aber
stattdessen hat er das gegenteil
erreicht
wie nie zuvor und damit genau das
gegenteil hatte er beabsichtigt die
präsenz
verringern aber jetzt ist die präsenz
noch sehr viel stärker es gibt
hunderttausende amerikanische
militärangehörige
in europa die demokratien der welt sind
revitalisiert und
sie haben zu einer ganz neuen stärke
gefunden und nicht nur die invasion
russlands und der ukraine erinnert uns
an die werte demokratie
sondern man sieht es auch in seinem
eigenen land ist leute gehen auf die
straße und sie werden dafür ins
gefängnis geworfen und viele junge gut
ausgebildete menschen verlassen das land
sie wollen nicht mehr diese massengräber
sehen und die bilder die die russischen
die russische armee in
ukraine
anrichten
200.000 russischer menschen haben das
land seit beginn des krieges verlassen
und das ist meine botschaft an das
russische volk ich habe mit russischen
führer seit jahrzehnten zusammen
gearbeitet
in allen möglichen fragen
rüstungskontrolle und so weiter und wir
ich möchte mich jetzt direkt und ehrlich
an euch wenden an das russische film vol
das russische volk seit nicht unser
feind
ich bin sicher dass ihr das nicht gut
heißt dass unschuldige kinder und
großeltern
getötet werden ich bin mir sicher dass
ihr das verurteilt dass städte zerstört
werden durch russische raketen und
bomben und das stete eingesetzt werden
und menschen daraus nicht
herauskommen das millionen von familien
abgeschnitten sind von ihrer zu hause
und das ukrainische kinder leiden
das russische volk
doch noch das ihr selbst in einer
solchen situation war in den späten 30er
und anfang der 40er jahre ihr habt
eltern und großeltern verloren und eure
generation hat schlimmes durchgemacht
die blockade von leningrad das habt ihr
gehört von euren eltern oder
großeltern überfüllte bahnhöfe wo
menschen versucht haben zu fliehen das
sind doch keine erinnerungen sind nicht
mehr erinnerungen aus der vergangenheit
sondern dass genau das was die russische
armee jetzt in der ukraine macht der 26
märz
vor kurzem noch waren wir eine welt
voller hoffnungen oder dieses volk war
ein volk voller hoffnungen und ihr auch
russisches volk und jetzt hat wladimir
putin dich abgeschnitten von der welt
und russland wird in das neunzehnte
jahrhundert zurückgeworfen das wollt ihr
nicht das habt ihr nicht verdient das
ist nicht die zukunft
die ihr verdient habt für eure familien
eure kinder und ich sage euch diese
dieser krieg ist eurer nicht würdig
putin muss diesen krieg beenden das
amerikanische volk wird an eurer seite
stehen und das mutige folgt der ukraine
meine botschaft an euch ist es
gibt keine freiheit ohne folgendes
europa wird jetzt seine abhängigkeit von
den russischen fossilen energieträgern
beenden und wir die usa werden dabei
helfen
[Applaus]
deshalb habe ich auch mit
der präsident der europäischen
kommission
dieses dieses programm verkündet
und es ist auch wichtig um die das
überleben des planeten zu sichern dass
wir so schnell wie möglich zu grünen
energieträgern gelangen und wir werden
dabei helfen dass wir alle gemeinsam das
schaffen können und die tage der
tyrannei müssen müssen vorbei sein sie
müssen zu ende gehen und zweitens müssen
wir natürlich die korruption bekämpfen
die vom kreml
ausgeht um der russischen bevölkerung
eine faire chance zu geben
wir müssen das als die demokratien
dieser welt
das ist nicht genug nur
hehre worte zu finden über freiheit und
demokratie sondern wir müssen
jeden tag hart daran arbeiten wir alle
jeder einzelne denn hier und in meinem
land auf deshalb
bin ich in dieser woche erneut nach
europa gekommen mit einer klaren
botschaft an die nato an die g7 an die
eu und alle freiheitsliebenden
nationen wir müssen
heute einige einen um die kämpfe der
zukunft zu bestehen das wird nicht
leicht sein aber wir müssen diesen preis
zahlen denn die die dunkelheit hat keine
chance geben die flamme der freiheit
das hat die geschichte immer wieder
bewiesen dass in den dunkelsten zeit
nach den dunkelsten zeiten der
größte fortschritt folgte und das ist
die aufgabe unserer zeit die aufgabe
dies generation erinnert euch wie die
berliner mauer eingestürzt ist wie der
eiserne vorhang sich wo das war nicht
die arbeit eines sollte so dass man alle
europäischen völker gemeinsamen
ist das paneuropäische picknick in
zwischen österreich und ungarn
und das begann mit der solidar in polen
und
gemeinsam
die völker erreichen dass die
sowjetunion nicht standhalten konnte und
wir sehen heute alle mutigen
ukrainischen volk das ist die kraft
ausreicht um nicht nur einen diktator zu
bekämpfen
in dieser stunde also
wollen wir sagen dass wir niemals die
hoffnung verlieren sollte die regierung
nicht auf lasst euch nicht entmutigen
habt keine angst sowie der papst das
damals gesagt hat
so hat
terium wieder zu errichten wird niemals
die herzen der völker gewinnen die
ukraine wird niemals
eine
eine trophäe für russland sein wir
wollen eine die helle zukunft für das
ukrainische volk in freiheit und
gott es will nicht an der macht bleiben
gott segne sie und gott würde unsere
freiheit zu schützen und unsere kinder
vielen dank für ihre geduld herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]